naît avec ce qu'on appelle un
spina-bifina c'est une anomalie
congénitale de la colonne vertébrale
pendant la grossesse il y a un truc qui
s'appelle le tube neural qui est censé
se refermer pour que là il se referme
pas correctement et du coup la moelle
épinière elle est pas protégée comme il
faut ta cause un certain nombre de trucs
pas cool comme des problèmes de
sensibilité des paralysies et des
douleurs six ans plus tard elle
contracte une autre maladie infectieuse
la polio et un peu comme Frida Kahlo Che
Guevara et Guns N' Roses tout le monde
en a déjà entendu parler mais il y a pas
grand monde qui sait vraiment ce que
c'est par contre personne ne porte de
t-shirt polo
ok j'ai rien dit c'est le diminutif de
poliomyélite c'est une maladie causée
par un virus qu'on attrape généralement
par voie orofécale le virus se développe
dans nos intestins et il finit par
envahir le système nerveux j'ai pris
dacalo c'est la jambe droite qui est
touchée et qui se développera pas
correctement et ça lui vaudra de la part
de ses petits camarades le surnom de
Frida jambe de bois
ce surnom il est cruellement
prémonitoire